le sourire est timide voire gêné
catherine chevalier n'est pas modèle
mais l'une des petites notes testament
de poilus un des projets collaboratifs
des archives yvelinoise je préparais une
exposition pour ma ville parce que je
m'occupe d'une association de généalogie
d'histoire locale donc je voulais
retrouver le plus d'informations
possibles sur les poilus de ces villes
d'aubergenville et donc comme de toute
façon j'allais piocher dans les archives
et faire des recherches je me suis dit
autant que ce soit utile aussi à
d'autres personnes et donc chercher les
testaments poilus pour pour le projet
des archers départemental comme
catherine une vingtaine de participants
a accepté de se prêter au jeu
ils donnent de leur temps pour recenser
les poilus compléter un wiki ou
décrypter des testaments
avec cette exposition les archives
départementales met en lumière lors 7000
bénévoles
c'est vraiment mettre une identité
derrière les contributeurs dans notre
travail au quotidien on parle de notre
équipe de contributeurs parce qu'on a
quand même un vivier assez important de
personnes très impliquées très présentes
qui participent beaucoup et puis
finalement comme beaucoup de projets
sont en ligne via des plateformes
informatiques
ce sont des noms des pseudos et on a pas
on les voit pas finalement capturé par
l'objectif de tirer mouny le photographe
des archives les portraits sont à
découvrir jusqu'au 17 novembre une
grande journée fait de l'histoire
conclure à l'exposition